do you get depressed when you go on the
road um not lately because I've taken
I've been taking somebody I take saundra
yokel I know the comedian no Sandra yeah
he's my love sound yes I take Sandra now
because I did I was getting very
depressed and I had an honest
conversation with myself and I was like
I don't give a [ __ ] anymore I want to
take someone that I think is funny and
good I'm not trying to cut local guys
out of work I'm just tired of being
lonely it's not just that even though
that I wanted a fright you want a friend
yes [ __ ] friend it's also a lot of
times they'll book somebody a feature
yeah that is normally a headliner
sometimes bitter to be there better
right yeah right and um they also do
local references on stage that get
bigger laughs that's my one that's my
one when I do [ __ ] hate it yeah well
that's my one thing whenever I go I
don't have any [ __ ] rules I don't
care what you do with your comedy yeah
it's your time on stage I get it yeah
but I say out of respect to me you're
not sitting and doing crowd work don't
sit and you don't do crowd work my two
rules you can't sit on a stool can't do
crowd work and if you stand the [ __ ] up
and tell comedy and then bring me on
stage and be cool that's it yeah it's my
rule books is so [ __ ] easy that when
people [ __ ] [ __ ] me and I've had a few
people that don't abide by those two
rules and I fire them I fired a handful
of people you have 100 percent we wait
well what do you go to that what you
guys know more you go to the mail I go
to the owner and the manager and I say I
can't work with this person anymore
and they say why and I go I we're not
getting along and I don't like it
and they're stepping on these things
that I don't like the MCS or it features
as well I mean I it's almost impossible
to fire a host yeah I thought I fired
hostess bit but but I've done it for
done it for a few different people
because I not a lot just a couple times
yes I got just clear and present a [ __ ]
you to me what they did was a [ __ ] you
to me yeah and it was like no [ __ ] you
I'm being so nice my only rule for you
yeah don't please don't sit down and
please don't do crowd work right this
one guy is so dirty and easy things guy
was a host he was talking about
finger-banging grandmother's yeah look
as a host right this kind of stuff so I
walk up to my go hey man can just not do
that dirty yeah you're you're the host
yeah you guys brought my headliner nope
well you're not what he said but
unfortunately or not I took second in
the Texas you know funniest person tells
well then in that case we should
sorry I didn't know that so I go I don't
give a [ __ ] I just don't do it and then
in the second view to defy me right just
to say [ __ ] you [ __ ] you he went even
worse like he'd bet the grandmother over
in the bed and all and so out when he
got upstairs I go you're fired
and he goes what he thought you weren't
gonna [ __ ] fire him I go yeah you're
fired he goes what why I told you he
goes yeah but you can fire me this is it
and you kind of walked back like in
shock yeah that's got a new host
yeah easy easy yeah that when I did I
did the Tampa wait Tampa Tampa Tampa
what is it yeah
improv improv yeah with Bob I love Bob a
Tampa improv years and years ago they
had I dude who was like 60 be my feature
the second night yeah the first night
with Sandro he was local yeah that's
right the sound was from Florida yeah
he's from down there yeah so he did the
first time but couldn't do another night
or something like that
and this [ __ ] guy comes up to me
before the show and he goes what kind of
stuff you're gonna be doing tonight I
don't know who the [ __ ] he is I don't
know he's a [ __ ] feature yeah
and I go oh just see the mice the stuff
that I usually do what what I'm like is
this guy a [ __ ] does he work here and
then he goes huh I've never seen your
stuff I don't know who you are
and I was like then it clicks then I'm
clicking well this guy doesn't work here
because why would he [ __ ] say that
yeah and then I go who are you he goes
oh I'm the feature and I go oh okay and
he goes but you know I I had learned
this club all the time Oh sounds like
okay man I [ __ ] you not
saundra and I had a good laugh about
this he goes on stage he does the
material that he he thinks is very very
good you know okay whatever I'm not
gonna sit in this pocket for long but he
gets off stage he [ __ ] comes to not
stays on stage and shake my head walks
off as I'm walking on doesn't even wait
for me as he shaked my hand he goes it's
a tough follow
[Music]
so what do you think I talked about for
the first 10 minutes him him Wow I
ripped him to [ __ ] pieces and the
owner was upstairs watching the whole
thing yeah yeah and they were buddies
like they were yeah and afterwards he
says I said I said yeah that [ __ ]
feature then he goes I know that guy
we're kind of and we known each other
for a long time and I go yeah well
[ __ ] I wasn't gonna not do what I did
and he goes no no it was very funny it
was still very he's like we are friends
I'm just you know letting you know I go
yeah ok I mean I didn't he that that was
my no no [ __ ] way moment yeah where
he goes so to follow I was like no
[ __ ] way yeah I go get I give I go oh
the first efforts were I don't remember
his [ __ ] name yeah and for the first
words out of my mouth I go give it up
for one of my uncles and then everyone's
kind of confused I go no no no though
they let this guy sometimes come here he
lives outside he lives right outside of
the club so if anybody on the way out
don't you know step around he's gonna be
out there tonight but just go by and say
hi to me he said he's sitting there in
the back kind of looking at me watching
yeah and I loved every second of it was
nice to be mean to his eyes but yeah
that was the rudest I remember that so
vividly thinking like what a [ __ ] and
ass back what an [ __ ] move yeah
[Music]